didn't connect with baller Here Comes Jack eichel
eel the other way feeds it across moving to his
left Gibson with a good save the rebound bounces
over the Stick of marches so no stick for Gibson
right now it's all the way in the corner and
barbashev feeds it to the right Circle eichel
rips it off the left shoulder room for CER at
Center former Western Michigan Bronco takes
a shot Gibson made the save rebound between the
circles fail to clear the Ducks however as it's
kept Alive by kisar petrangelo one timer fought
off by Gibson nice little bit a back checking
there by silverberg he denies entry not once but
twice now Hutton will just throw it in on net
it's gloved off by Gibson but Anaheim able to get
possession and bring it back the other way color
dumps it in and now pursues in the corner rolls
off over Bren Bal comes right to the goal mouth
and a good save made by Thompson there areso had
a hat trick on Thursday in the Vegas win at home
against Winnipeg shares the team goal scoring lead
with half a dozen barbashev leads eel out of the
Vegas Zone falling is lome odman situation as a
result and barbashev finishes in the goal crease
Vegas strikes first well you see the strength and
the power of Jack iel just flat out dominant in
that game and he gets away from Jackson lome and
look at this pass over the stick lands flat he
sees barers driving that far post and he delivers
just a beautiful strike barbashev he just needs to
keep that stick blade down on the ice and angle
it upwards it's a chip in for barashev and sent
the other way by Mark Stone Gibson out to tap
to the corn as it came off the end wall and
a loose Puck again bounced on by petrangelo puts
it on net forcing Gibson you have to have someone
driving the middle of the ice to back off that
defense enri puts it behind the net silverberg
joined by Z right back to silverberg and another
great a saved by Logan Thompson he's only made two
saves in this game they both from in pin from in
close Gibson out to play it back in the Anaheim
Zone and it's broken up by Kier back to the line
room for pahal hands it off Hutton from the dot
at 54% he wins that one Anaheim turns it over
at the Blue Line and Carlson got a lot on that
shot good save by Gibson and Carlson all over but
Tonto as he tracks him back below the goal line
and gets the puck back but McTavish Steals on the
left boards and Away to Center he comes anaheim's
leading scorer carries it across the line still
possesses in the corner looks back safety valve
is leushin at the line instead he goes rink wide
and mikov shot is blocker toide by Thompson to
the line kept in by lbushkin and McNab sweeps
it ahead William Carlson two goals last night
in the win against the Avalanche trying to sneak
it ahead to dorv but that went off es skate and
coming back into the Zone it's Carlson snaps
it ahead room for Terry his long bid steered
aside by Thompson that's about a strategic of
fouron four sequence as you'll see pass through
the middle to Stevenson drops it off and stone
shot tipped at the goal Malou by cter zis comes
away with it followed up by Carl hands it off to
Terry Terry middle of the ice too hot to handle it
went right through zis mnov keeps it in off the
side of the net Terry brings it into the goal C
and Thompson in the open Ice by Sam Carrick and
then Troy Terry tries to jam it home from close
range Vegas on the other hand plus nine in second
periods this year Stone goes right up the middle
of buin knocks it down gets it on net Thompson
covers 5 minutes gone second period Bower knocked
his man down in the corner we've yet to have
a penalty in this game Carlson rolls off the
boards gets the pass and a good save by Gibson
the com almost left it behind and now zis does
carry into the Vegas Zone Rink White Pass taken
off the skate Terry Let It Go perhaps the best
save of the game by Thompson so he's off to a
a better than decent start I would characterize
it as so four on four that means room for eel
as he brings it in on right wing and he scores
High short side that is a big time shot by eel
see I I jack eel's got the puck and he's got a
lane to the net Fowler is pointing at the Winger
to pick him up but he's on the wrong side of eel
so you're essentially letting just a superstar
Player move right in inside the dot and roof
it so for eel is third knocked Away by eel and
Carlson sends him away shorthanded eel stop by
Gibson that's huge what a stop by John Gibson
Carlson sends it ahead give and go and he'll
go behind the net to get it back from vrono chips
it to the corner Howen spun around there and now
Anaheim trying to outnumber the defenders in the
corner They Come Away with a puck the open man
Fowler his shot blocked got it back and Henrik
scores the Ducks get him [Music] B makes a great
stop with time winding down on the power play it's
kind of a broken play the puck squirts free for
Adam Henri traffic in front throw the puck on the
net and finds a again the activating defense of
Vegas keeping pucks alive hunting from behind
the net rolled it in front got it back turns
oh Stoned by Gibson in the third [Applause]
[Music] they play catch across the top of the
Zone popping out to help out Ross Johnston out of
mnov nice pass in front but it went off the heel
of Leon's stick tucks get it back mnov in front
for carrot score Sam Carrick it's a brand new
game and another point for mAh Zone they're
all heading the wrong way when the puck turns
over and Sam Carrick is wide open and boy
he just opened up Logan Thompson watch The
Patience by character one one little fake and
then he just Taps it through the five hole and
just like that the ducks have come all the way
back this team has already got four comeback
wins where they've trailed in the third period
pulls up in the corner pops it into the middle
went through vrono over to mikov he flips
a backhander tipped just wide by McTavish
was some good creativity McTavish has to get
through the referee but keeps possession out
high it's minakov again vrono high slot leushin
save and the rebound chop wide Again by MAV they
score thrown in front and Anaheim has their
first lead Mason Mavis right at the top of the
crease
his team is something else in the offensive
zone they're the team with more energy that
was a good stop by Thompson but get a right
back out to him and nobody could tie up the
Stick of Mason Mavish gets all his leverage on
that stick blade and just swats it between the
pads and Anaheim comes all the way back
and takes a one goal lead here late the
one they call up the boards kep kept at
the point by Theodore his pass broken up
along the boards by Fowler eel embroiled
with Terry and it's brushed the link of
the ice again by Carrick and it's in off
the post and in that's a good goal in Ed
le battle for possession along the boards
everyone's hacking away at it eel can't
control it and there's the flip by Carrick
I I guarantee you he had no intention of
putting that puck on the net the Ducks will
take it that puck just curled off the inside
of the post and look at the bench reaction
they come to their feet at Honda Center and
rightfully so the golden knights had not lost in
regulation in the regular season in their last
20 games but tonight the ducks with four goals
in the third period of race a two goal deficit